PRESIDENT IS THE FIRST PERSON TO
JUMP STRAIGHT FROM TELEVISION TO
THE PRESIDENCY.
HE MAY NOT BE THE LAST.
WHEN I MET LAST NIGHT DURING THE
GOLDEN GLOBES.
THERE WAS A HEAVY FOCUS ON
ENABLED THAT BEHAVIOR FOR YEARS
OF COURSE, BUT LAST NIGHT THEY
COLLECTIVELY VOWED TO STOP IT.
THE BIGGEST STAR WAS
OPRAH WINFREY, HARVEY
WEINSTEIN'S OLD FRIEND, WHO WON
A STANDING OVATION WITH THIS.
>> I WANT ALL THE GIRLS WATCHING
HERE AND NOW TO KNOW THAT A NEW
DAY IS ON THE HORIZON!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
AND WHEN THAT NEW DAY FINALLY
OF WHOM ARE RIGHT HERE IN THIS
ROOM TONIGHT, , AND SOME PRETTY
PHENOMENAL MEN FIGHTING HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY BECOME THE
LEADERS WHO TAKE US TO THE TIME
WHEN NOBODY EVER HAS TO SAY TO
ME ALSO AGAIN.
>> Tucker: IF YOU DIDN'T WEEP
US ARTIST TOM HANKS DID YOU ARE
JUST NOT HUMAN.
THE SPEECH DIDN'T JUST WHEN
OPRAH APPLAUSE.
MANY PEOPLE PREDICTABLY OR TALK
THERE ARE 24 HOURS TO FILL IN
CABLE NEWS.
THAT SPECULATION WAS FUELED BY
REPORTS ON MONDAY THAT OPRAH IS
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING A RUN.
JENNIFER RUBIN, WHO POSED AS A
OPRAH-YATES 2020!
BILL KRISTOL, TWEETED
#I'mWithHer.
JOY READ SUGGESTED OPRAH IS
ALREADY THE PRESIDENT AT LEAST
IN SPIRIT.
"SWITCH BACK TO THE
GOLDEN GLOBES TO WATCH OPRAH GET
DON'T RESPECT THE PRESIDENT OF
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: A MOMENT OF
SERIOUSNESS NOW.
OPRAH IS VERY TALENTED.
ONE OF THE GREAT COMMUNICATORS
OBVIOUSLY.
IF SHE RAN IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY SHE WOULD WIN.
IT'S ALL DAYTIME TV VIEWERS
VOTING IN THAT PRIMER AND SHE
WOULD WIN.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF YOU ARE
SENATOR GILLIBRAND OR ONE OF THE
PEOPLE WHO SPENT YEARS KIND OF
BLOWN OUT BY OPRAH?
>> I GUESS THE WAY MARCO RUBIO
OR JEB BUSH FELT OR TED CRUZ
FELT WHEN TRUMP BLEW THEM OUT.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING FOR US TO
LOOK AT AS A VACUUM, SO TO
SPEAK.
SHE IS NOT DIVISIVE.
SHE MAKES PEOPLE FEEL WARM
INSIDE AND RIGHT NOW OUR COUNTRY
IS VERY DIVIDED.
WHAT SHE DID LAST NIGHT WHEN SHE
HEALED US, SHE BROUGHT US ALL
TOGETHER AND THAT IS WHAT IS
NEEDED.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON, HOW DID
SHE HEALED US?
>> SHE HEALED US BECAUSE SHE
WHETHER YOU ARE A WOMAN, SHE WAS
INTERTWINING RACIAL DIVISION.
SHE TALKED ABOUT NOT JUST WOMEN
COMING TOGETHER, BUT WOMEN AND
MEN COMING TOGETHER.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED IN A LEADER.
>> Tucker: WOMEN AND MEN COME
TOGETHER KIND OF NATURALLY AND
HAVE FOR BIOLOGICAL REASONS FOR
QUITE A WHILE NOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN WITH THE
#MeToo MOVEMENT IS WOMEN
STANDING UP AND SAYING WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO US WHETHER WE ARE
WORKING IN HOLLYWOOD OR POLITICS
IS NOT GOOD.
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE MEN WHO ARE
ALSO SAYING THE SAME THINGS
RATED OPRAH MADE A CALL TO ARMS
TO SAY EVERYONE NEEDS TO COME
TOGETHER.
>> Tucker: C WEREN'T BOTHERED
BY THE PICTURES OF HER KISSING
HARVEY WEINSTEIN OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT?
THAT DIDN'T SEEM A LITTLE WEIRD?
>> THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
WERE KISSING HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
EVEN OUR OWN PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW
HAS BEEN ACCUSED OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
>> Tucker: IT'S ONE THING TO
GO FROM KISSING HARVEY WEINSTEIN
TO BEING THE FACE OF #MeToo.
SHOULD THERE BE AN INTERMEDIATE
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
INTERMEDIATE STEP.
THE INTERMEDIATE STEP IS A 1990
OPRAH ACTUALLY PASSED A BILL
THAT MADE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
ABUSE CHILDREN WERE REGISTERED.
ACTS IN 1990.
SHE HAS A HISTORY OF DOING
THINGS --
>> Tucker: OF BEING IN THE
CONGRESS IN PASSING LEGISLATION
AND NOW SHE'S HEALING?
>> SHE HAS A HISTORY OF MOVING
THINGS FORWARD BY USING HER
PLATFORM AND THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED.
WE NEED A LEADER WHO USES THEIR
PLATFORM TO DO THINGS THAT ARE
POSITIVE.
DONE FOR COUNTLESS YEARS.
AND IN 1990 DONALD TRUMP EVEN
SAID IF HE HAD A VP IT WOULD BE
OPRAH WINFREY.
>> Tucker: FOR SURE.
I WONDER IF IT'S BEING A
UNIVERSALLY BELOVED DAYTIME TALK
SHOW HOST AND TALKING ABOUT
WHATEVER SHE TALKS ABOUT, IT'S A
WOULDN'T SHE BECOME SLIGHTLY
SOME OF THE THORNY ISSUES OF THE
DAY?
>> MAYBE SHE COULD.
LOOK AT DONALD TRUMP.
HE HAS BECOME MORE DIVISIVE.
THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT WITH
OPRAH WINFREY, SHE STUCK TO THE
SCRIPT, SHE STUCK TO HEALING,
SHE STUCK TO MAKING SURE OUR
NATION IS COMING TOGETHER.
WITH OPRAH WINFREY --
NOW.
>> AND BEING SO HONEST.
>> Tucker: HEALING THING, YOU
FELT THAT?
>> YOU DIDN'T HAVE A TEARJERKER
MOMENT?
>> Tucker: I WEPT LIKE A
CHILD.
INVASION SUPPORT OPRAH?
YOU THINK THIS IS NOT THE OPRAH
I KNOW, THE ONE WHO GETS SUPPORT
FROM BILL KRISTOL?
>> IT'S NOT THAT.
FOR ME I FELT THAT 2018 IS OFF
TO A GOOD START WHEN WE SAW
SOMEONE WHO WAS RALLYING THE
COUNTRY IN A POSITIVE WAY.
THAT BANDWAGON, THAT'S GREAT.
IT'S GOOD THAT WE ARE COMING
TOGETHER.
DESCRIBING A RELIGIOUS FIGURE.
SHE HEALS PEOPLE, SHE PASSES
LEGISLATION WITHOUT EVEN BEING
IN CONGRESS.
>> SHE USES HER PLATFORM FOR
DOES.
REMARKS, BUT I'M GOING TO KEEP
THEM TO MYSELF.
>> WE CAN CRITICIZE HER BUT WE
HAVE TO GIVE HER HER KUDOS AND
THAT IS THAT SHE USES HER
PLATFORM EFFECTIVELY.
>> Tucker: I WILL NEED TO GO
TO CONFESSION IF I EVEN THINK AN